- This program is presented by
University of California Television.
Like what you learn?
Visit our website or follow
us on Facebook and Twitter
to keep up with the latest UCTV programs.
(upbeat music)
- Thank you for coming this afternoon.
My name is Paula Varsano
and I'm a professor
of East Asian languages
and cultures and the chair
of the Foerster Lectures Committee.
We, along with the graduate council,
are very, very happy to
present V.S. Ramachandran,
this year's speaker in the
Foerster Lecture Series.
I'm also very pleased to tell you a bit
about how the endowment
supporting the Foerster lectures
on the immortality of the
soul came to UC Berkeley.
It's actually a story
that really exemplifies
the ways in which this campus is linked
to the history of California
and in particular to the Bay Area.
In 1928, Miss Edith Zweybruck established
the Foerster Lectureship
to honor the memory
of Agnes A. Foerster and her husband,
Constantine E. Foerster.
Edith was a public school teacher
for many years in San Francisco.
And the teaching profession, in her eyes,
was the perfect opportunity
to develop a true knowledge
and love of the spiritual values of life
in the young minds entrusted to her care.
Edith's beloved sister, Agnes A. Foerster
shared her high ideals and her hopes,
as did Agnes' husband, Constantine.
A lawyer by profession, he was a man
of high intellectual achievements
and of rare personal charm.
Although he passed away at the age of 37,
he had achieved an enviable
place at the San Francisco Bar
as one of its most
highly respected members.
For several years prior to his death,
Foerster was a law
partner of none other than
Alexander F. Morrison,
one of the most prominent
of San Francisco attorneys, for whom
our Morrison Memorial Library is named.
In her last days, Miss
Edith Zweybruck expressed
her deep and abiding interest
in the spiritual life
by creating this lecture series
on the subject of the
immortality of the soul.
She believed that through the
medium of great universities
and the words of scholarly lecturers
she might shed new light upon a subject
that has interested the
world for centuries.
So we have to thank Edith Zweybruck.
And now about our lecturer.
Sometimes the best way
to characterize a person
is to consider what kinds of questions
he or she likes to ask.
And here's a question
that is always being asked
in various ways by our speaker.
And I quote him here.
How can a three pound mass of jelly
that you can hold in the palm of your hand
imagine angels, contemplate
the meaning of infinity,
and even question its
own place in the cosmos?
Now, what kind of person
can ask this question
in a way that doesn't sound rhetorical?
Poets can do that.
And Doctor V.S. Ramachandran
is, indeed, a poet of sorts.
Officially, however, he
serves as the director
of the Center for Brain and Cognition
and is a distinguished professor
at the University of California,
San Diego, as well as
an adjunct professor of
biology at the Salk Institute.
He has also been called the
Marco Polo of neuroscience
by Richard Dawkins,
and the modern Paul Brokaw by Eric Kendau.
But as pithily impressive as
these titles and these epithets
may be, they actually do very, very little
to reveal the mind-teasing
pathway he has followed
and on which he leads us
in the work that he does,
and in the contributions that he makes.
Doctor Ramachandran is renowned
for his ongoing inquiry
into the field of cognitive neuroscience
that is the intersection of neurology
and perceptual psychology.
To steal a few words from the
title of one of his books,
he is actually a neuroscientist on a quest
for what makes us human.
Building on his early
work on visual perception,
Ramachandran has led
pioneering experiments
in behavioral neurology,
taking cues from malfunctions
in perception, including
phantom limbs, synesthesia,
and xenomelia, to delve
into the unique ways
in which the human brain forms and deforms
the workings of mind.
Laypeople are perhaps most familiar
with his controversial
assertion of mirror neurons
as playing a central role in
the unique evolution of humans.
His approach to neurology has been
to revisit classic syndromes,
bring them to the lab, determine
their broader significance,
and devise new treatments where possible.
Of course, Ramachandran, many of you know,
is a very prolific author,
and he's published over 180
papers in scientific journals,
five of which were invited review articles
for Scientific American.
He's the co-author with Sandra Blakely of
"Phantoms in the Brain, 1999,"
which has been translated
into nine languages,
and formed the basis for a PBS special.
His BBC Reith lectures
were published in 2003
in a volume titled "The Emerging Mind,"
and were dubbed by the
Nobel Laureate David Hubel
as bold, irreverent,
original, and ingenious.
His latest book, a New
York Times bestseller,
is "The Telltale Brain."
After training as a physician
in Stanley Medical College
in Madras, India,
Ramachandran attained a PhD
from Trinity College and
the University of Cambridge.
He's an honorary fellow of the
Royal College of Physicians,
London, and the recipient
of two honorary doctorates.
Ramachandran has received many accolades
throughout his career.
He was awarded the
Henry Dale Medal in 2005
and was elected to an
honorary life membership
to the Royal Institution of Great Britain.
The president of India conferred on him
the highest honorific title in India,
Padma Bhushan, in 2007.
And besides the BBC Reith
lectures he delivered in the UK,
he also gave the Gifford
Lectures in Scotland.
Time Magazine named him one
of the most influential people
in the world in their 2011 Time 100.
Finally, before I cede the
stage to Doctor Ramachandran,
I would like to leave you with
a few words by Ted Cruiser,
US Poet Laureate from 2004 to 2006,
who also asks what makes us human.
He words it differently though,
and much more mournfully
than our speaker does.
Here we will not find the mind's brain
imagining angels or contemplating
the meaning of infinity.
In the closing lines of Cruiser's poem
"In the Hall of Bones,"
after cataloging the array
of skeletons that he
found in what seems to be
a natural history museum,
he writes these words:
"And then, here's man,
"all matchsticks, wooden spoons,
"and tongue depressors, wired together.
"A rack supporting a leaky
jug of lust and worry.
"Of all the skeletons assembled here,
"this is the only one in
which once throbbed a heart
"made sad by brooding on its shadow."
It's my pleasure to welcome
Doctor Ramachandran to Berkeley.
(audience applauding)
- Well thank you for that
amazing introduction.
I'm delighted to be here
and honored to be invited
by the committee to do this
lecture, Foerster Lecture.
When the committee first phoned
me up about this and said
I was to talk about the soul,
the immortality of the soul,
I said, "Well, that's
easy, I'm happy to do it."
(audience laughing)
And then I did a double take
and I realized what I was getting into.
But then fortunately they
reassured me that in fact,
it doesn't have to be anything
directly related to the soul,
but so long as it's tangentially relevant,
which means essentially all
phenomena in the universe.
So I'm gonna approach
the problem of the soul
not so much the soul but the self.
It's after all the immortality of the self
that we're all concerned about.
We call it the soul.
And I'm gonna use two approaches.
Mainly one approach,
but I'm not gonna deal
with the metaphysical question of soul,
which is extensively dealt
with in Indian philosophy
and in Western philosophy as well...
But if you sort of pause
and introspect on the self,
there are many attributes,
it's kind of common sense,
but roughly speaking, there's embodiment.
One of the most obvious
aspects of the self
is, it's you're anchored in one body.
I'm not anchored in Tony's
body, I'm right here.
But we'll call that into
question in a minute.
Then there's a sense of
continuity in space and time.
You all have a calendar.
Sense of agency.
Sort of like the free will.
Sense of unity and coherence,
despite a diversity
of sense impressions and
memories over a lifetime.
You feel like one person.
I'm one guy, one name, one
bank account, one spouse,
so on and so forth.
And a sense of privacy and individuality.
And then finally, most mysterious
of all, self awareness.
Self is not aware of its self.
Sort of like an oxymoron.
There's a curious, recursive quality to it
which is hard to come to grips with.
I'm not gonna talk about all
the attributes of the self.
That would take a whole week.
But let's talk about embodiment
and partly about privacy.
And from the point of view,
cognitive neuroscience and neurology.
And the way we deal with
this, the way we study this,
is by looking at patients.
We can do brain imaging,
it's one thing we do,
but mainly we do
behavioral, old-fashioned,
19th century behavioral neurology.
We look at patients who
have sustained an injury
or a change in a small part of the brain,
and then producing characteristic
changes in their behavior
and trying to correlate
structure and function,
trying to explain the changes
in behavior in terms of
the anatomical organization
of the normal human brain.
To give you some insight into the question
of what's mediating that
particular function.
So let me begin with a bang
and talk about a syndrome
which few people even heard of.
It's called xenomelia.
Xenomelia is the name we gave it,
but it's also known as apotemnophilia,
unpronounceable name but apotemnophilia.
These are first patients...
I'll mention one example,
second example of it,
dean of an engineering
school who came to see me
at the age of 70, had just
retired at 70 years old,
and he had harbored,
through his entire life,
he'd harbored a secret
urge, as he described it,
to amputate his own healthy arm.
Going back as far back in
childhood as he can remember.
He's a perfectly normal
guy in every respect,
not obviously psychotic or
depressed or mentally disturbed,
no neurological findings,
completely normal,
led a normal family life, had
friends, had a job as a dean.
Everything seemed normal, except
for this one particularity
that he had this urge.
And by then I discovered
that many of these people,
it's not that rare.
It is rare, but not that rare.
And about one third of
them to half of them
go and get it amputated.
This is not some mild
obsession these people have.
There's few serious clinical consequences,
the loss of the limb.
So then I said, "Why
did you come to see me?
"Do you want us to treat you or cure you?"
He said, "No, I enjoy it,
I don't wanna be cured.
"I want you to remove
the arm, give me a letter
"so I can go get it removed.
"And I can't do it here in this country.
"I'll go to Mexico, across the border,
"it's legal to get a
healthy limb amputated."
I'm not making this up,
this is what he said.
Later I checked on this and it's true:
you can get it amputated
in Mexico and in Canada,
but you can't do it here.
So many patients travel north
or south to get it amputated.
And what would cause this?
The first thing (mumbles) is,
one of the things you learn
in clinical medicine is
first talk to the guy.
You know, 90% of the time you
figure out what's going on
in his brain by just talking to him.
You don't need to do brain imaging,
you don't need to do
even clinical testing.
I said, "Do you feel like this
arm doesn't belong to you?"
He said, "No, no it's the opposite.
"It feels like it over belongs to me.
"It's intrusive.
"It's intruding itself on me.
"And I want it removed."
I said, "Okay," and I
started thinking about this.
And I said, maybe what's gone wrong
is you look at the surface of the brain,
that's the somatosensory
cortex, so there's one,
it's called the Penfield
map of the body surface.
And the entire surface of the body,
the body skin surface is mapped
onto the post sympathizer...
There's a vertical cleft going
down the side of the brain
called the central surface.
Behind that cleft there's
a vertical strip of cortex,
it's shown in brown there.
So that'd be the left hemisphere,
if you were going to touch my right side,
closer to that is on the left hemisphere.
There's a complete map
of the body's surface
on that post-central gyrus there.
That map is shown in the next slide.
Many of you may have seen this before.
It's got some peculiar features
which I will come back to.
But I said, well maybe in this guy,
it was a very naive, phrenological hunch,
maybe in this guy that part
of the brain is missing.
The hand is not there.
You don't know how much
of this map is present,
the scaffolding is present at birth,
and how much of it is
shaped by experience.
And I'm gonna talk about
that in a few minutes.
But for now, let's assume
it's hardwired, partly.
Maybe it's congenitally missing the arm,
and that's why he feels it's alien
or it doesn't belong to him.
So we did the obvious experiment
of galvanic skin response,
poked him with a needle, gently,
in different parts of the body,
and obtained electrical
skin conduction responses.
And we thought we would find no responses.
One of the things that clued us in
to this as being a neurological
rather than a psychological disorder,
if you ask him where did
he want it amputated,
he'd take a felt pen, and
he would draw an exact line
just above the elbow or below the elbow
or just above the hand.
Very precise line, often
irregular line, sloping line,
and then if you let him go home,
don't tell him you're gonna retest him,
but bring him back after six months,
he'll draw exactly the same line.
Unless he's being deliberately
deceptive, got it memorized.
It's very unlikely he's doing that.
So this suggests that...
Why would the precise line matter?
Some vague inclination
to get the arm removed,
why would the precise line matter?
In fact there are many
psychological theories of this.
One psychiatric theory holds
that it's a cry for attention,
that's why they want their arm removed.
Why arm?
Why not remove the nose or the
ear or something like that?
Why the arm always, or the leg, right?
Seems pretty drastic way
of getting attention.
Another theory, believe it or not,
the Freudian theory, the
guy wants his arm removed
in order to create an amputation stump,
to resemble the giant penis.
I'm not making this up.
You can see this in the literature.
So we thought we'd come
up with a neurological,
phrenological theory of what's going on.
Then we drew the line with the felt tip,
poked him with a needle in
different parts of the body,
to see if the galvanic
skin response is normal
below the line as opposed
to above the line.
We expected a diminished
galvanic skin response
below the line, because
that part of the arm
is not represented in the
brain, according to our theory.
Well we found the opposite.
As often happens in science.
We found below the line
there's a huge galvanic skin response.
Above the line, is perfectly
normal as you would expect.
Is that clear?
Okay if you poke somebody with a needle,
unless it goes to S1 of course, and S2,
the somatic representation of the body,
but it also goes to an area
called the insular cortex,
and from there it gets
into the anterior singular
and from there messages
cascade down the sympathetic
nervous system, producing
sympathetic arousal to the pain.
And then this manifests as a
change in sweating of the skin,
which in turn can be measured
as a change in skin resistance.
You put two electrodes in the palm
and I scare you with a
needle or I scare you
with a lion, you start sweating.
This registers as a
fall in skin resistance.
Base of lie detectors.
Any anxiety, any panic
will produce resistance.
So clearly, he was
registering a higher response
to the alienated part of the
limb than to the normal part,
which is opposite of what we predicted.
But hang on a second.
So we said, well our basic,
early theory was wrong,
so what's going on here?
Then we resorted to brain imaging.
I don't have any pictures to show you,
but basically what we found
was this map was normal,
the one I just showed you, S1 is normal.
S2, which represents joints,
muscles, and light touch,
that was also normal.
We said what's going on here?
Everything's normal.
Then we went to in superior
parietal lobule, SPL,
wherever four is, superior parietal lobule
is where you create a
polysensory representation
of your body image.
You close your eyes, your vivid
impression of your own body,
inhabiting your own body, the movements
of your arms and legs and all that,
that sense which was called
body image by Henry Head
and Lord Russell Brain, two
real neurologists, by the way,
who called this the body image.
And that combined sensation
from hearing, touch, and vision
is in the superior parietal lobule.
In that map, there is no
response from the hand.
So that map was abnormal.
There's a hole, to put it crudely,
corresponding to the
hand he wanted amputated.
So what's going on in this patient is,
the messages from the hand and arm
are reaching the somatosensory
cortex completely normal.
So the messages, sensory
signals are normal,
sensory cortex is normal, S2 is normal,
but they have nowhere to go to,
'cause there's a hole in
that region of the brain.
So this creates a discrepancy
between the incoming sensory input
and there's no place for them to go to,
and the brain aborts discrepancy,
that signal goes to the insular
and possibly the amygdala,
generating a galvanic skin response.
(grunts) right?
So here we have an example of...
We've taken the Freudian
theory and discarded it.
By and large, that would
be completely wrong,
and then replaced it with
an anatomical theory,
which we can test in a few
hours using a GSR machine,
and then do more
sophisticated brain imaging
and show that we're on the right track.
This shows the power of this approach,
cognitive neuroscience.
We can take a bizarre,
seemingly incomprehensible
neurological disorder, a
person wanting his arm removed,
and reject the traditional explanation
in favor of an anatomical explanation
based on the known neuroanatomy
of the sensory pathways in the brain.
Now, can you cure the disorder?
We haven't found a way of treating it yet.
In fact, they don't wanna
be cured, as I said before.
But the next topic I'm gonna deal with...
So this is typical of what we do.
We take syndromes that have
been known for a long time,
either rare ones or common ones,
like synesthesia is very common.
I'm gonna talk about that later today.
Phantom limbs are quite common,
I'll talk about that as well.
Our rare ones, and bring
them from the clinic
to the laboratory and then
do systematic experiments,
to find out what's going on,
and sometimes we're actually
able to help the patient.
Now this at the start
it doesn't always work,
looking for anomalies.
Because every now and then...
You only hear of the success stories.
Nine out of 10 times
it's a wild goose chase.
Anomalies in neurology.
Neurology and psychiatry are
full of anomalous syndromes.
Nine out 10 times a wild goose chase.
You only hear of the success stories.
I'll give you three examples
of wild goose chases.
Very briefly.
There's a syndrome called
De Clerambault Syndrome.
How many of you know about
De Clerambault Syndrome?
Nobody.
See?
Pretty obscure.
Even most neuro and psychiatrists
haven't heard of it.
It refers to a syndrome that's defined as,
it's accepted in psychiatry textbooks,
a young woman, typically young woman,
who develops the delusion
that an old, rich, famous man
is madly in love with her
but is in denial about it.
(audience laughing)
Funnily enough, the
converse of the syndrome
has not been described,
where an older gentleman
develops a delusion that a young hottie
is sexually interested in him,
but is in denial about it.
This is much more
common, I can assure you.
(audience laughing)
Another bogus syndrome is chronic
underachievement syndrome.
This is actually found in textbooks.
Chronic underachievement syndrome.
My day it used to be called stupidity.
(audience laughing)
The third syndrome, my favorite,
is oppositional defiant disorder, ODD.
This young spirited youngster
daring to challenge the establishment.
The psychiatrist challenged her parent...
The man who invented
the syndrome is genius,
because any attempt by the
patient to disprove the syndrome,
the pretend syndrome, can be construed
as additional evidence for the diagnosis.
Leaving that aside, every now and then
you stumble on legitimate syndromes
that give you key insights.
So for example, apotemnophilia.
Now I'm gonna talk about something else,
this you heard before, many of you,
but I'm gonna repeat it, the gist of it.
Phantom limbs.
An arm or leg were amputated
and you continue to feel
its presence is called a phantom limb.
Some years ago, nearly 15 years ago
we had a patient with a left arm amputated
and we made a specific prediction
based on work on monkeys run
by Mike Merzenich and others.
So nobody had tested it on humans,
so we had a patient sitting in my lab,
whose left arm had been amputated,
we blindfolded him and simply took a Q-tip
and touched different parts of his body,
and asked him, "What do you feel?"
He said, "It's my right
shoulder, and my chest."
So here's a patient sitting
in the chair, blindfolded,
took a Q-tip, touched
different parts of his body,
did a routine sensory neurological exam.
"What's that?"
"That's a Q-tip."
"What are you touching?"
"Right chest."
"That's my right shoulder,
my left shoulder.
"Left upper arm.
"Oh my god you're touching
my left phantom thumb.
"And my phantom pinky, and
my phantom index finger."
We found there's a complete
map of the missing arm
on the face, and you can
actually plot receptor fields.
You can plot receptor fields.
Like the thumb was there.
Ball of the thumb, index finger, pinky.
And you can send him home,
bring him back after a month
and it's exactly the same.
No way he could've memorized that.
And why is this going on, happening?
Well we can do a bit of detective work.
Go back to the Penfield map.
Notice that the map is completely,
as a map should be, continuous,
except for one fact: the
face is not near the head,
where it's supposed to be, near the neck,
it's below the hand.
Is that clear?
So we said, what's going on?
And when you amputate the arm,
these sensory signals don't
get to be handed in the brain.
Signals from the face can
normally go into the face area,
invade, and cross and invade the territory
vacated by the missing hand.
So there's this cross-wiring.
You ignore the arm and the hand,
there are no signals coming
to this region of the brain,
the hand region.
That region's hungry
for new sensory input.
The sensory input not coming from the face
came to the face area,
invades the territory
corresponding to the missing
hand, activates the cells,
and those cells misinterpret the signals
as coming from the missing phantom hand.
So when you touch the face
he thinks you're touching his hand.
So you can have fun with this.
We took a Q-tip and put
it in ice-cold water
and put it on his face, and he said,
"Oh my god, my thumb
feels ice-cold, doctor."
So the reorganization
is morality-specific,
it's not higgledy-piggledy.
Touch goes to touch, warm goes
to warm, cold goes to cold.
On one occasion, water started
trickling down his face,
accidentally, and he said,
"Oh my god, I can feel
the trickle of the water!"
And he took his other hand, normal hand,
and followed the trickle,
"It's coming down here,
"it's coming down here, oh
it stops here at the wrist."
Where the water stopped.
So it's exquisitely
precise, the reorganization.
Just for fun I said,
"Raise your stump and
point to the ceiling."
The phantom is pointed
to the ceiling, upward.
Then I put the water here,
started trickling down,
I said, "What do you feel?"
He said, "Oh my god the
water is trickling upwards,
"defying the laws of gravity."
You knew the patients
often enough, you realize
that they don't make up stories like that.
Alright, I can continue along these.
I'm running out of time soon,
I'm gonna skip a lot of stuff.
Can do brain imaging to
show the reorganization
has indeed occurred.
The other interesting thing
about phantom limbs is,
the patient can often move the phantom.
Majority of patients can move the phantom.
But about a third of them,
the phantom is fixed or immobilized.
And often in a painful position.
The patient will say,
mimic the phantom positions
with his normal hand and will
say, "It's like this, doctor."
Occupying it's like this.
"My hand is extending, hyper-extending,
"so my knuckles are touching
the back of my wrist.
"It's anatomically impossible,
but my hand is doing it."
And it's like that
movie, what is the movie?
Where the head spins around?
(audience member mumbles)
Yeah, so it's anatomically impossible
and it's excruciatingly painful,
"I wish I could straighten my wrist
"and the pain will go away."
"So why don't you try?"
"I'm trying, I'm trying, I'm
sweating, I can't do it."
I'm gonna cut a long story
short, we hit on the idea
of putting a mirror there
and showing the reflection
of the mirror, we can go into detail
during the question and answer later,
put a mirror inside a cardboard box,
and the phantom, the clenched phantom,
often they will say, "The
fingers are biting into the...
"The nails are biting
into the palm, doctor,
"and it's excruciatingly painful."
There's no nails, there's
no palm, there's no hand.
It's a phantom.
It's a serious clinical problem.
Become profoundly
depressed, lose their jobs,
on occasion they contemplate suicide.
So you put a mirror there
and you have the patient
clench the normal hand
and look at the reflection
of the normal hand in the mirror
so that the reflection of the normal hand
is superimposed optically
on the phantom hand,
so you visually resurrected the phantom.
Then you say, "Okay send
symmetrical commands
"to both hands to open or close."
He says, "I know you're
telling me that I can do that,
"my left hand, it will not open."
I said, "Just take a look
in the mirror and see."
He said, "Oh my god it
looks like it's opening.
"And my god it also
feels like it's opening,
"it doesn't merely look
like it's opening."
Which is not surprising, it's optics.
But it feels like it's opening,
and the clenching spasm is removed,
it's gone, the pain is gone.
Then I said, "Remove the mirror."
I removed the mirror.
Then try with your eyes
closed and imagine it, and,
"No it doesn't work, I keep
trying but it doesn't work."
Put the mirror and then,
"Wow, it's opening, it's
opening, it feels good."
So I said, "Well, maybe...
"You can't carry around
a mirror all the time.
"Maybe you can get to a
point where you can practice
"with the mirror one hour a day,
"and after about a week or two or a month,
"you can dispense with the mirror,
"you can just move it on its own."
He can just unclench it
whenever he wants to.
So I sent him home with a box, only $2,
sent him home with a box.
And then after two weeks I phoned him up
and I said, "Have you been practicing?"
He said, "Yes I've been practicing.
"When I keep my eyes open,
the pain gets relieved
"for about an hour, and then it comes back
"with a vengeance.
"And then I put the mirror
back and it goes back again.
"So I keep doing refills.
"I know you want it to go away
permanently, but it doesn't."
I said, "Fine, c'est la vie, you know?"
Then after a week he phones me,
and he's all agitated on the phone.
I said, "What's wrong, Derek?"
He said, "You're not gonna believe this."
I said, "What?"
"It's gone," he says.
I said, "What's gone?"
I thought maybe the box was gone.
He said, "No, no, no, not the box.
"The phantom limb which I've
had for the last 13 years.
"The phantom limb is
gone, it's disappeared."
I said, "What do you mean?"
He said, "It's gone."
I said, "When?"
"Like three days ago.
"I've been trying to reach you."
And I was a bit worried about this
because human subjects and ethics,
because I've permanently
modified this guy's body image,
if what he's saying is true.
Then I said, "Well does it bother you?"
He said, "No, the pain that I had
"in my phantom elbow, my phantom wrist,
"and my phantom fingers,
I've never had those pains.
"In the last three days
I don't have a phantom."
We can go into the question
of why this happens later,
but clinically, this has been tried
in several clinical trials,
one in the New England
Journal of Medicine,
so you can see the...
Published in the New
England Journal of Medicine
from Walter Reed.
You can see with the mirror
they say the pain drops
to almost no pain.
With the covered mirror and visual imagery
the pain actually goes up
until they crossed over
and then the pain drops
again in the mirror.
And now it's widely used in
clinics around the world.
Now, surprising, curing
pain in a phantom limb
with a mirror is surprising enough.
Now as you see there's
a lot of variability.
Only about half the patients are helped.
In about half of them
the mirror does nothing,
typically patients who've
seen them for a long time.
These variables need to be studied.
There's another disorder which
I want to tell you about.
Speaking of mind and body and Lekov here
has done more than anybody
else to talk about links
between mind and body.
But here is a powerful
example you see in the clinic.
Ordinarily we think of pain as one thing.
But there's in fact two kinds of pain.
There's chronic pain and acute pain.
Acute pain, you touch the
kettle and you withdraw
to prevent further tissue injury.
Obvious adaptive value.
Chronic pain is the opposite.
Immobilize the arm.
You've a tiny metacarpal bone fracture,
and your finger becomes
painful, immobilized,
there's a reflex immobilization
to prevent further injury
to the finger, and it gets swollen
and it gets inflamed and it
gets warm and it gets red.
All signs, it remains swollen, warm, red,
painful, and inflamed.
And then the bone heals after two weeks,
all the change is reversed,
the inflammation subsides,
pain goes away, the finger
starts moving again.
That's normal, 99% of people.
In about one or two percent of
people that does not happen.
The injury heals, the
bone heals, in x-ray,
but the pain persists with a vengeance.
It continues to be immobilized, paralyzed.
It gets swollen, it gets warm.
Normally then it spreads
to the entire hand.
Entire hand gets warm, swollen,
painful, immobilized, paralyzed.
Entire arm gets paralyzed,
swollen, immobilized,
from the starting from the
little metacarpal bone fracture.
So what's going on here?
I don't know.
We still don't know.
But one thing, the paralysis
I think is partly due
to what we call learned paralysis.
Every time you attempted
to move this finger,
move the arm, brain was sending a single,
"Ouch, it's painful, stop moving it."
So there's a habean link
between the very attempt
to move the hand and
the excruciating pain.
So the brain gives up and
says "Stop moving your hand."
So you get this pseudo-paralysis
arising from punishment.
So we said, "How do you cure this?"
Well let's put a mirror here, of course.
And put the other hand there,
and send a symmetrical command,
you're gonna get a visual
illusion that the paralyzed,
swollen, painful hand is
actually moving with impunity.
But he's not actually moving it.
There's an optical twin that's moving.
He's seeing the reflection
of his normal hand moving.
But with that unlearned the
learned pain phenomenon.
But this is a wild hunch,
even by my standards,
and we're setting out to do it,
fortunately another group did it,
Halligan, Marshall and Wall, in England.
And they...
That shows you an example of RSD.
They did a similar
experiment with a mirror
and found dramatic recovery.
In fact, what's astonishing is,
when you put the mirror there...
Here's a guy for months he's been swollen
and paralyzed and inflamed and painful.
He moves the normal hand, in a few minutes
the inflammation stops, not only the pain,
but the mobility returns and
the swelling starts subsiding.
And the temperature starts falling.
You can't fake a fallen temperature.
So that convinced me that it was real.
And then when I saw one of
the authors was Patrick Wall,
who's the world's leading expert on pain,
he's experimented on placebos as well,
so his name was in the papers,
I figured this must be a real phenomenon.
Since then, there's been
about four or five controlled studies,
there's been blind controlled studies,
placebo controlled studies,
also now it's the accepted
first line of approach treating RSD
in clinics around the world.
It's an extraordinary example to me
of mind-body interaction.
That a mirror is producing changes...
Vascular changes in sympathetic pain,
changes in swelling, all of
it, temperature, all of that.
All online.
It's also being used for
stroke by the way now,
mirror rehab, and also for neglect,
which I won't go into
now, for a lack of time.
Now just when I thought I
was done with phantom limbs,
I came across another phenomenon.
I started reading Rizzolatti's
work on mirror neurons.
I speculated on this,
and jumped off my seat when
I first heard the talk.
Everybody here knows about mirror neurons,
especially here in Berkeley.
They're neurons in the front of the brain,
prefrontal cortex, roughly
homologous to Brocal's area, B5.
These neurons normally
are the garden-variety
motor command neurons which
when a monkey or a person
reaches out and grabs a
peanut, a neuron fires,
orchestrating the series of motor twitches
required for grabbing the peanut.
About 10% of these
neurons Rizzolatti found.
They'll also fire when I watch George here
reaching out and grabbing a peanut.
They've been quickly dubbed
monkey see, monkey do
neuron, or mirror neurons.
So they're sort of simulating
doing a virtual reality
simulation of your impending
action, is the claim.
Now, there's also sensory mirror neurons,
they're equally interesting.
Discovered by Christian Kaiser
in S2, the sensory cortex.
Remember I showed you the map
of the sensory areas of the brain.
When you touch my left hand,
right somatosensory cortex,
S1, S2 cells are activated,
there's a map.
This has been known for a long time
since Lord Adrian, goes
back 70 to 100 years.
Now, a subset of these
neurons, about 10% of them
will react to my watching
George's thumb being touched.
So this is very interesting
because we can call them empathy neurons.
Because the neuron is effectively saying,
what's happening to George is similar
to what would happen to you
if your thumb were touched.
So empathize with George,
you know what it's like to feel his touch.
Same thing with pain, you
go to anterior singular,
there are neurons sensitive to pain.
If you poke my thumb with a needle,
it goes to my anterior
singular and I say, "Ouch."
But if you poke George's
thumb with a needle,
a subset of the same neurons fire
and I can empathize with George.
But here's an interesting question:
Wouldn't I shout, "Ouch" when
he's poked with a needle?
The same neurons are firing.
Wouldn't I withdraw my hand
and I will simply watch
George's hand being poked?
A couple of possibilities.
One possibility, obvious possibility,
is I wear my normal skin
sending a veto signal
saying, "Don't worry, you're
not actually being poked.
"Empathize with George, by all means,
"but don't dissolve into him.
"Don't withdraw your hand suddenly
"because that's maladaptive,
it'd be a waste of time.
"So empathize with him, know
what it's like to be George,
"in George's shoes right now,
"but don't withdraw your
hand, that would be foolish."
So I looked at this and I said,
"Well the obvious prediction
is if I amputate my arm
"and look at George being poked,
"I should feel the pain in my phantom."
Because the afferent signals are gone.
There's no veto signal.
Is that clear or obscure?
So in the hundred years
that we've known about phantom limbs,
nobody answers this question.
If you poke somebody with a needle
when a phantom limb patient is watching,
does he feel the poke in his phantom?
The answer is yes.
We've seen in three patients now,
they watch another patient being poked,
they feel the pain in their phantom.
So we call these empathy
neurons or Gandhi neurons.
(audience laughing)
Now there's some debate about
whether mirror neurons are significant,
whether they're important or
the same mysteria of the minds,
action understanding action, production,
all of this, just is it
old-fashioned psychology,
new words to describe
empathy and things like that.
We won't go into that.
This patient went home
and he had a smart idea
and we talked about it
before he went home.
He feels excruciating phantom
pain in his phantom arm,
cramped, phantom cramping pain.
He can't do anything about it.
We were already getting ready to start him
on the mirror protocol, before that
he simply watched his
wife's hand being massaged.
And of course he felt a phantom massage
in his phantom hand, he claimed.
'Cause he needed to
relieve the phantom pain.
This is not, unlike the mirror procedure,
this has not been tested in
clinics, in a clinical setting
using placebo controls.
But if it works, it'll be a clear example
of a practical application of
the idea of mirror neurons.
Leaving aside all the
arcane, theoretical debates
about how significant they are,
practically, in the clinic,
to alleviate phantom pain.
That guy doesn't care (mumbles) the theory
or the mind or what it is.
His pain goes away.
Now another prediction we made,
this is kind of cute, actually.
Going back to the motor neurons,
there's a condition called OCD,
obsessive-compulsive disorder.
In one particular variation
which is particularly
troubling to the patient
is ritual hand washing.
A person accidentally touches a doorknob,
this mere minor contamination
elicits acute anxiety,
almost panic, and the guys
incessantly wash their hands,
to the point of erosion of
the hand, fingers and skin.
And then we said, "Well what if he simply
"watches another guy washing his hand?"
Sounds stupid.
Some of my best experiments
begin as jokes, by the way.
(audience laughing)
So I said, "What if he
watches somebody..."
There's an experiment done
with Jalal, Baland Jalal,
a student in my lab.
So sure enough, in about
two thirds of the patients
we've seen with OCD traits,
hand washing compulsions,
they watch another
person washing his hands,
they get relief.
And the interesting thing about this
is it can't be response bias
because they're surprised by it.
"How the hell...?
"Why should him washing his
hand produce relief in me?
"It doesn't make any sense."
They express surprise.
So I think we're on to something,
a potential treatment for OCD.
Because you could have
an app that shows you,
as soon as you get the
urge, you look at your self
washing your own hand, you
don't have to go to the toilet
and spend half an hour, right?
So another example of
a clinical application
for something like OCD.
It's a topic that I know very
little about, by the way.
I'd like to switch gears now and talk
about phenomenon which
we call synesthesia.
Which was documented
first by Francis Galton,
in 19th century, first
cousin of Charles Darwin.
He noticed some otherwise normal people
in the general population.
He said it was rare, one
in 1,000, one in 500,
now we know one in 50
people have synesthesia.
So this condition is one where a person
is otherwise completely normal.
If he sees a printed number
on a white sheet of paper,
like five is red, six
is blue, seven is green,
eight is chartreuse, nine is indigo,
and so on and so forth.
The color remains constant
for any particular individuals
over years, stable over years.
It's different for different people,
not the same colors for different people.
Although there are trends, we
can get to that if you want.
Now since the discovery
of synesthesia by Galton,
there have been hundreds of case reports,
but no attempt to understand
what's going on in the brain
or what causes it.
And in fact, people brushed it aside,
classic example of an anomaly in science,
a Kuhnian anomaly, which
people brush under the carpet
and say, "It doesn't make any sense.
"What do you mean five
is red, six is blue?
"It doesn't make any sense."
Well often anomalies can
pave the way to new discovery
and new areas of research.
So we thought, well why
not study these people?
And the standard explanation
of synesthesia, by the way,
one explanation is these are just crazy.
That's not an explanation.
Even if it's true, let's put
that aside for the time being,
come back to it as a last resort.
Second explanation is,
they're high on drugs.
And sure enough, it's about
seven times more common
in Berkeley than at UCSD.
(audience laughing)
But leaving that aside,
the fact that drugs
influence synesthesia is not evidence
against synesthesia being
a legitimate phenomenon.
It makes it more interesting.
Why would some drugs
enhance this propensity
to see numbers as color?
The third explanation is
they're just childhood memories.
They've been playing with
the refrigerator magnets
and five was red and six
was green and seven was blue
and eight was yellow
and so on and so forth.
This doesn't make any sense to me
because why does it run in families?
Galton himself showed that
synesthesia runs in families
and possibly in a Mendelian
fashion, so it's inherited.
So you have to see the same madness
as being passed on from
generation to generation,
which didn't make much sense.
But you had to keep in
mind the possibility.
And then if it's true,
if it's just magnets,
why don't we all have synesthesia?
Why only a subset?
Obvious questions.
The fourth possibility is more
ingenious but a bit vague.
Along the lines that George
and I have been thinking.
I'm not saying you're
vague, but I'm vague.
That is that maybe
they're being metaphorical
when they say five is green.
Maybe it's like oh, say, F sharp is blue.
It's like saying cheddar cheese is sharp.
The cheese isn't sharp.
You rub it on your skin it's soft.
You say, "No, no, no, the taste is sharp."
But there's a circularity there.
Why do you use a gustatory metaphor,
a tactile metaphor to describe
a gustatory sensation?
There's a whole area of
research that this leads to
which we don't have time to go into.
But this may be on the right track,
as you can see, this is
what I'm gonna argue.
First of all, are they crazy?
We did a number of experiments
to show that they are not.
It's a legitimate phenomenon.
And in a subset (mumbles)
there are two kinds
of synaesthetes, the
projectors and the associators.
Projectors are the minority,
maybe about 10 to 15%,
synaesthetes, and we
stumbled on two of them,
luckily when we started doing
the research on synesthesia.
Associators are more difficult to study.
They constitute 80 to 90% of them.
So let's talk about projectors.
So we said, "How do you know
they're not making it up?"
Well we designed this display.
You've got a synaesthete
who sees numbers as color.
So we show normal people
this panel of fives
with some two scattered among them.
Can you find the twos?
One there, one there, one there.
They form a shape, either a square
or a triangle or a circle.
And it takes ages.
Takes 20, 30 seconds before you spot the
upside down triangle.
A synaesthete looking at
it sees it much faster.
He says, "Oh I see an
upside down red triangle."
If you're a projector synaesthete.
Now if he's crazy, how
come he's better than us?
This has been confirmed
by Jamie Warr, by the way,
in London, in a larger group of...
This experiment done with Ed Halbert,
he used to be a student here at Berkeley
before he turned into a grad student.
Also there's phenomenology.
You talk to these patients,
for them it's not a patient,
subject, sorry about that.
Synaesthete I saw recently
said, "Eight is blue."
And I said, "Do you see the
blue in your mind's eye?
"Like when you think of Cinderella
"you think of a pumpkin
or you think of a chariot?
"Or do you literally see it blue?"
And she said, "No, no,
I actually see it blue.
"It's not like Cinderella and the pumpkin.
"Because there I can think
of Cinderella and her gown,
"Cinderella and mice.
"Whereas here I can only think of blue.
"The irresistible urge to see blue.
"And not only that, in my case,
it spills out of the color,
"Spills out of the
letter and forms a halo,
"a dusty halo around it."
Now why would that be?
The first thing I did was
simply put an amoeba around it,
and the halo gets blocked,
part of the halo gets
blocked by the amoeba.
These kinds of phenomena you can't explain
in terms of vague
psychological associations.
Suggests strongly that
they're sensory in character.
You can even put an illusory
contour around the A,
it gets blocked by the illusory contour.
We can get back to where
that's happening in a minute.
So what's happening in
synesthesia, what's going on?
Rumor that it runs in
families, that's one clue.
It's also (mumbles) that
synesthesia is seven or eight times
more common among artists,
poets, and novelists
and other creative people
than in the normal population.
That's another piece of the puzzle.
We've got all these pieces of the puzzle.
Why is it eight times more common
among novelists, poets, and artists?
Why?
We'll see in a minute.
And in the subset of synesthesia
we've got the projectors,
we stumbled on, the
anatomy is straightforward.
Greg Hubbard and I were
looking at brain atlases.
We saw that the area for
numbers shown in the red,
discovered by Stanislas
Dehaine and Tim Ritger
in our lab, in our department,
shows where graphemes are
represented, including numerals.
And the green path is (mumbles) Z4.
This is involved in processing color.
We said, "What's the
likelihood of the most common
"type of synesthesia,
number-color synesthesia
"and these two are
right next to each other
"in the fusiform gyrus of the brain?"
Well we said, "It's very
unlikely to be a coincidence.
"Maybe there is some
accidental cross-wiring
"between number and color."
So every time they see
a black and white number
it activates a number
node and cross-activates
a color node spontaneously so
they see a particular color.
Now why would there be cross-activation
of this kind in these people?
Remember the clue comes
from the fact that it runs in families.
Remember that in the
fetus, in early embryology,
in early, early childhood, perhaps,
everything is connected to everything.
That's an overstatement,
but a tremendous
redundancy of connections.
But then these excess
connections are pruned away
by pruning genes to create
a modular architecture
that characterizes the adult brain,
including number area and color area.
So if these pruning genes are mutated,
there's defective pruning,
then some redundant connections
are gonna be left behind,
for example the mutant pruning gene
is selectively expressed
by transcription factors
in the fusiform gyrus alone,
you get this quirky
number-color synesthesia.
And what about the higher synaesthetes?
Where it's not just the
number that produces,
visual appearance of the
number that produces...
So-called associators, what about them?
Well we did a simple
experiment on these people,
these projectors.
We said, we asked a very simple question
which had not been
asked about synaesthetes
since the 100 years we've known about it,
since Galton's time.
Instead of showing them a five,
why don't you show them a V, a Roman five?
Instead of showing them an
Arabic six or an Arabic seven,
I should call them Indian by the way,
but instead of showing an Arabic number,
why when you show them a
Roman five, what do they see?
Do they see a color?
The answer is, I've
never met a synaesthete
who's seen color in a Roman number.
So it's not the concept of the number
creates the color, it's
the visual appearance,
which fits the idea that fusiform gyrus
encodes the visual appearance,
not the higher level concept
of numerosity, ordinality, cardinality,
and all that good stuff.
Which, by the way, I think
happens in the angular gyrus.
We've long known that the angular gyrus,
if the left angular gyrus is
damaged, you get discalculius.
If you ask him to subtract 17 from 21,
he'll say, "Oh it's 14."
He will glibly say it's 14,
and is sure that he knows it for certain.
Discalculia's another whole lecture.
So I think in the projector synaesthetes,
the cross-wiring gene is expressed,
you have the cross-wiring gene,
we get number-color synesthesia.
In the associator synaesthete,
it's expressed higher up
so the idea of sequence is mapped
onto higher color areas in the brain.
In the color processing hierarchy.
So it's expressed higher up.
I can show you a diagram later.
In the vicinity of the angular gyrus
you get higher synaesthetes
or lower synaesthetes.
Which would explain why some
of these higher synaesthetes
also experience not only numbers as color
but days of the week as color.
Monday is red, Tuesday is
blue, Wednesday is chartreuse.
And months of the year as color.
Again, it seems completely
and utterly incomprehensible.
What do they all have in common?
Months of the year, days
of the week, and numbers?
Sequence.
So I think the angular gyrus
is where the action is.
And now there's some
research using DT imaging
by Rumka Holt in our lab,
she's visiting our lab,
she has shown that in fact,
if you do DT imaging,
there's more white matter
in the vicinity of the angular
gyrus in the associators
and in the fusiform
gyrus in the projectors.
But this is still very preliminary,
I should add a note of warning.
Okay here's another fun example,
and we can play games with these people.
How many of you can read that?
Raise your hand.
Very tough.
Now squint your eyes.
(audience laughing)
George you can't read it yet?
Remove your glasses.
Okay.
Alright, now guess what happens
when you show this to a
projector synaesthete?
Projector synaesthete says,
"Well I see a jumble of
colors but I don't know why,
"because you know I
can't see any letters."
Then they say, "Oh wait a
minute, I know why that's red.
"It's an N.
"It's an O, that's why it's blue.
"S, E, oh I see, ha ha ha."
Okay so they're seeing
the colors being activated
but it's hidden numbers.
Before they reach consciousness
and register as graphemes.
So the blind side for
numerals in synaesthetes.
So what I'm claiming is,
in these individuals,
those hidden numbers are activating
the color area of the brain,
and then they're evoking
a proper (mumbles)
they're evoking a number
area of the brain.
Activating the number area.
Evoking the appropriate color even before
the message is sent higher up
to be recognized as a grapheme.
So you're seeing the
colors and using the colors
to infer what the grapheme...
The most striking
example of this I've seen
is two colorblind synaesthetes.
Sounds like an oxymoron.
This person could see a
limited range of color
because of vision cone
pigments in the eye.
Limited range of color
in the external world,
but when they saw numbers,
they would see colors
that you would never see
in the external world.
They call them, charmingly
refer to them as martian colors.
And the reason again...
We've seen two patients like this.
The reason again is because
the cone pigments are deficient
so they can't see colors
in the real world,
they see only limited range.
But they saw a number, the
number activates a number node
and cross-activates color neurons
which can't experience those
colors in the real world
because the receptors don't exist.
It's hardwired for seeing
quote-unquote martian colors.
Is that clear?
This again eliminates any possibility
of learning being the
basis of synesthesia.
How can you learn a
color you've never seen?
Another phenomenon Galton,
the astute Galton noticed
was what he called number lines.
When I ask any of you to
imagine numbers in front of you,
one to 10, you may be
crudely going left to right,
one, two, three, four,
and it's very vague,
there's nothing really clear.
But in some individuals, Galton noticed,
and again we find this about
one in 50, to one in hundred,
will see a vivid,
three-dimensional layout of numbers
in the visual field.
One is here, two is here,
and it's convoluted,
not straight line left to right.
It's convoluted, 1, 2,
3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9,
10, 11, 12, 13, 14,
15, 16, 17, 18, 19, 20.
And often doubles back
on itself like this.
So fifteen may be close to two,
instead of being close to
16 or 14 in Cartesian space.
And this has been ignored for 100 years
and Ed Hubbard and I and David
Brian did some experiments
to establish that the
people are not faking it.
We used the number-distance effect,
I don't have time to go into it.
So they're not faking it.
The number line affects their
reaction time to numbers.
So then there'd be mixed
results on this phenomenon.
But everybody agrees with
me about the phenomenon,
the question is why does it arise?
Why would some people see numbers
and imagine numbers like...
Again, it's a classic example
of an anomaly in science.
And people ignore it for that reason.
I don't know the answer to
why they see it this way,
unlike the grapheme color synesthesia
where I had a clear answer.
But only one reason, the
one thing I can think of is
arithmetic and numbers and mathematics
is a recent event in human evolution,
maybe 5,000, 10,000 years old.
And the brain can't invent
a completely new algorithm
from scratch to handle
numbers, ordinality,
sequences and all of that.
So what it does is, it adopts a trick
using preexisting maps in the brain.
Maps go back into Ionian times
in our fish-like ancestors.
Brain is full of maps.
So you map on the ideal
concept of numerical sequence,
ordinality and cardinality and quantity.
Onto spacial map to create a graph.
If something goes awry with
this remapping of this concept
of sequence onto a spacial map,
you get these peculiar number lines.
Now how do you test this idea?
I have no idea.
But it's an interesting idea nonetheless.
Now some of these people
also have, I'm almost done...
Some of these individuals,
and we've studied a number of these,
David Brian has studied them in our lab.
Have what we call calendar lines.
Here is a woman we studied recently.
And when I ask any one of you to imagine
a calendar in front of you,
typically most people imagine
a rectangular calendar.
Like a real calendar,
January, February, March,
and then you know, so on and so forth.
Very vague, nothing very clear.
It's in your mind's eye.
These people see a very clearly laid-out,
three-dimensionally laid-out calendar,
always circular, never rectangular,
and never in the cardinal plane
but in the transverse plane,
like a hula hoop going
through their chest.
January, February, March, April, May...
Current month always occupies
the ego of the calendar.
You see this repeatedly
in different subjects.
And here's an interesting
one that George would like.
You'll do interesting experiments on them
like what if you tilt
their head like this?
Does the calendar tilt?
The answer is no, it stays like
a water level, where it is.
Here is the best part.
If you ask them to rotate
their head like this,
what happens to the calendar?
The calendar's here like a hula hoop.
Rotate their head like that to the right,
what happens to the calendar?
Calendar, in this particular case,
remains attached to the head.
Sorry, attached to the body.
It's in sort of...
Put it crudely, body-centered,
not head-centered.
But the exciting thing is,
she noticed that the left side
of the calendar became fuzzy
as she rotated her head, like
a real, physical calendar.
Why in the hell would a mental calendar
be like a physical calendar?
And she said also, she organizes her life,
her time and space and calendar,
using this calendar helps her organize
her otherwise chaotic
and meaningless life.
And then she looks back
and she looks on the other
side the opposite happens.
So she can use this mental calendar
to organize her daily
activities and her future,
project herself into the future.
Surely a vital part of
what you call the self.
And not only that, here's
what we're testing currently.
If she does this, memories,
episodic memories,
events that happened in
January, February, become fuzzy.
She has to look there
to retrieve memories.
She's an undergraduate student,
I don't think she's read Lekov's book,
so I don't think she's making it up,
but we don't know yet for sure.
We're testing her.
Lovely example of embodied
cognition, her neck muscles
are gaining access to
memories, episodic memories.
Now, where is it happening?
This is what we always do, when we look
at peculiar phenomenon, to nail it down,
show what's going on, so
it's a real phenomenon,
the patient's not making it
up, and try to figure out
what's going on in the brain
and a possible cure if it requires curing.
What's going on in the brain?
Well, I said the angular gyrus
must play a critical role in sequence.
I think it plays a
critical role in calendars.
This can be tested.
But then, what about hippocampus?
It's got play cells, it's
got two kinds of cells
involved in spatial and
temporal labeling of events.
And now it turns out, looking at atlases,
there are direct connections
between the angular gyrus
and the hippocampus,
the inferior longitudinal fasciculus.
And that's shown in the next slide.
So I'm claiming that the
human mental calendar,
which we take for granted but we use
for organizing our lives,
life would be completely meaningless...
People usually attribute
it to fondle structures.
I think fondle structures
only involve paying attention
to specific regions of the calendar.
Calendar itself is
constructed by interactions
between the left angular
gyrus and the hippocampus.
Okay I'll just conclude there
by saying that all of these problems
which are tangentially related
to the problem of self,
how you construct the body image,
how you feel a hand cut inside your body,
embodied cognition, projecting
yourself into the future
and creating a calendar around
which your life revolves,
your problems are considered intractable
but we can sort of begin to
just scratch the surface.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)
- Hi, my name is Eric.
So I have a question about synesthesia.
- Sure.
- You mentioned that
synesthesia runs in families.
So there's a genetic factor.
In your studies, did you notice
that the same synesthesia,
the color-number
synesthesia is hereditary,
or is it different?
- It's a problem statistically
because the most common form
is number-color or letter, grapheme-color.
I think there is a
tendency for the same form
to be inherited, but it's not been...
The only thing we know for sure
is if you have one type of synesthesia,
you're much more likely to have another
unrelated type of synesthesia as well.
Which supports my
defective pruning theory.
The same transcription
factors are expressed
in two different regions
in the same brain.
And you're gonna get two unrelated types
of synesthesia co-occurring,
more often than by chance.
- Are these like functional
areas that are sort of...
The function's kind of fused together?
- To give you an example,
the number-color synaesthetes
are often the ones with
the calendar synesthesia.
And often the ones with
tone-color as well.
They don't always have to occur together
but often do, or much
more often than by chance.
- Thank you.
- Sure.
I didn't mention about creativity,
but I'll get to that later.
- Hi, thanks for a great talk.
I wanted to say something
here a little more
about the metaphorical views
or the anthropomorphism
involved with talking about
the neurons in the brain.
When you say that an area
that normally corresponds
to an amputated limb or something,
when you say it's starved for
stimulation or it's hungry
or something like that, so
what is that describing?
Why would a non-stimulated
area in the brain care
whether or not it was stimulated or not?
So in what sense is there a
causal explanation for saying...
Or the cross-wiring sounds
a little more plausible
than saying oh it's hungry or it's starved
or stimulation wants to move around?
- I was just being loose
with the terminology.
Sorry.
It's a legitimate question.
- I forget the name of that syndrome
where somebody wants
to have an amputation.
- Xenomelia.
- Xenomelia?
- Yeah.
- Great.
Just a question of ethics in that regard.
- Before it's not done yet.
- Well but do we mutilate somebody
because their heart wants
to look differently?
That's the kind of issue that has come up
and have you seen some advances
in figuring that ethical question out?
- I'm interested in those issues,
but it doesn't come up in our case
because the patient, no surgeon
will ever do the amputation.
They have to go across
the border to get it done.
- At least in the US.
- Thank you.
- Hi.
Do you have any thoughts of
what is going on in
schizophrenia, for example?
The self is broken or I don't know how...
Maybe do you have some thoughts about it?
- I've thought about it,
but not enough to say
anything intelligent.
Thank you.
- These unexplained thought
forms like synesthesia,
any evidence or maybe a feeling
of immortality of the soul?
(audience laughing)
- It's a question for George.
- Quick question.
You didn't wanna touch on, in this talk,
but just a brief background from you
on the ancient civilizations of India,
the whole Vedic tantra Agama literature.
How do you connect it yourself with some
of the phenomena that
you've talked about today?
- There's the metaphysical
issues that are being dealt with
in Vedic literature or (mumbles).
In Hebrew literature, in
neo-Christian literature
which I haven't touched on
because I don't have
any expertise in that.
I'm very interested in it, obviously.
The self is something that
I can come to grips with,
at least partially, so I
focus my attention on that.
But I like sharing this
quotation from the Upanishads,
where he says that the individual self,
human beings are like windows.
Let the light pass through.
And there's a central light
illuminating the building
from inside, which is
called (foreign language),
or universal spirit or
consciousness or whatever.
When an individual dies, the window shuts,
but the universal spirit continues shining
through other windows.
It's a comforting thought
but I don't have any
deep thoughts about it.
- Thank you.
- It's a good question, though.
- I wondered if you'd done
any research on photophobia?
People's feeling pain
with regards to color.
- I know a couple students who have that.
We haven't studied it.
Fascinating question.
But I can't tell you anything about it.
- Like whether pain's...?
Okay.
Thanks.
- Hi.
You just briefly mentioned
that you hadn't explored
creativity in synesthesia,
and I'm just wondering
about work done on...
I know with music, different
composers who are very skilled
who have synesthesia, different composers
see different colors, like
Scriabin and Messiaen.
These composers...
Has there been any research
on where that happens
or what's the effect that's
going on in the brain
and why they each see
different colors with sound
and all of that?
- Well we can't get that specific,
but I do have a theory
about why synesthesia
is so much more common among
artists, poets, and novelists,
why it promotes artistic talent.
The reason is, I think that the same gene
that's expressed selectively
in fusiform gyrus
or angular gyrus producing
this quirky association
of synesthesia, if it's
expressed throughout the brain,
there's gonna be creative
cross-connectivity
throughout the brain, and
ideas and concepts are also
in far-flung regions of the
brain, like when you say
Juliet is the east and Juliet is the sun.
So Juliet is the sun, does that mean
she's a glowing ball of fire?
You don't say that.
You say she's warm, she's nurturing,
she's radiant like the
sun, she rises in bed
like the sun rises in the east.
She's the center of my solar system
like the sun is the center
of the solar system.
You can make as many
associations as you want.
And these people have excess connections
connecting far-flung brain regions,
have a greater propensity to
link seemingly unrelated ideas.
And this is what we
call artistic creativity
or facility in metaphor.
In fact, you can even think to put it
in phrenological terms, each
node has a penumbra of meaning,
like Juliet of the sun
has a penumbra of meanings
associated with it.
And because of the excess connections,
the penumbra is bigger in synaesthetes.
There's greater zones of overlap
between two seemingly unrelated ideas,
so it makes them more creative.
Hence the higher incidents of...
And hence, by the way,
the higher prevalence
of synesthesia gene.
Why would one in 50 people
have this quirky ability
of linking five and red?
Because there's a hidden agenda
because the gene makes the
outliers in the population
more creative and imaginative in general.
And the penalty you pay for that
is the minority who sees five as red
but doesn't do them any harm.
Otherwise there would
be no selection process
to maintain this gene in the population,
it would've drifted away a long time ago.
- Thank you.
But regarding specific details
of colors and all that,
we haven't studied that.
It's a good question.
- On the same subject of creativity,
I'm coming from linguistics
like literature,
and I'm trying to bring new findings
of neurolinguistics into how the brain
acts and reacts in writing.
And I know a little bit about words
that has to do with visual and kinesthetic
and auditorial, but I
wonder if there's something
that is written on the subject of the self
seeing itself in words
or not seeing, you know?
Did you write anything about it?
'Cause you said you--
- There are literatures dealing with that
but I'm not the right person to ask,
but it's a good question.
There is literature pertaining to that
which I can't think of it off hand, but...
- Okay because the last
doctor that you said
that you're not gonna
discuss is self-awareness.
And I wonder if there's
some passages there
in terms of self-awareness in creativity.
No?
- Not that I know of.
- I had a question
regarding the phantom limb.
Did you try using different
mirrors like concave and convex
mirrors and seeing what kind of effect
it would have in removing the pain?
Or was it just?
So the types of mirror that you used
in the phantom experiment...
Yes.
- The only thing we've seen is if you use
a magnifying mirror, the
phantom looks bigger,
the pain also is amplified,
momentarily, fortunately.
- So there is a direct
correlation in terms of...
- Yeah.
Hasn't been studied carefully
but appears to be, yeah.
Good question.
- Thank you.
- So I had a question about the case
of martian colors and the
correlation of synesthesia.
So is there a difference between people
who develop colorblindness later in life
due to macular degeneration
or those who are colorblind
from birth so congenital?
- We only studied the
ones who are from birth.
- Okay, alright thanks.
- Two of them, but it's a good question.
- I have a question about synesthesia.
You seem to argue in your
talk that synesthesia
is more inborn, not learned...
Or no?
- It doesn't make any sense
if synesthesia is inborn.
You're not born with letters
of the alphabet and numbers.
- Right that's what I'm wondering about.
- What I meant to say was the propensity
to link arbitrary shapes
like numbers and colors
is inborn in some people.
Not that the phenomenon
of synesthesia is inborn.
- But why would it be
always letters and numbers?
And why is always letters or numbers...?
- There's a tendency for
that region of the fusiform
to represent arbitrary shapes,
and there are rare cases
of synesthesia with faces
showing colors, and faces are
also in the fusiform gyrus,
as Charlie here has shown many
years ago, very elegantly.
- Alright, thank you.
- Hi, thanks for being here.
- Sure.
- Two short questions.
One is, you mentioned
something about neck muscles
and memory at the very end
of your talk and I missed--
- What I meant to say
was that in the person
with episodic memory who
claims, we're not testing this
rigorously by measuring her
repeatedly after a few weeks
and a few months, giving
her some striking episodes
and not telling her about it,
but if you go by what she's saying,
if she looks to the right,
a portion of the calendar
is on the left becomes fuzzy,
as it would if it were a real calendar.
She said the memories of
those events become fuzzy too
and hard to drudge up in consciousness,
until she turns around and
looks directly at the calendar.
So it's helping her to...
That's what I meant with the neck muscles
gaining the access to episodic memories.
That's the extreme
version of the hypothesis.
- Okay.
Also, what do you think is happening
when someone sees someone
getting massaged across the room,
and let's not use the anomalous case,
let's just say anybody,
they see somebody getting massaged...
Can they start feeling a
little bit better or...
I know you haven't studied that but...
Like what do you think is happening?
- Seems to me that
because of your afferents,
you know that you're not being massaged,
and that kind of silences it.
So I doubt very much you'd
experience any benefit from that.
But there are a group of
people who congenitally
have some (mumble) of hyper-empathy.
It's claimed by Sarah Blakemore.
I haven't seen subject myself,
but I trust her judgment.
So what you're saying may be true
of a minority of the population,
20% of the population.
But in the case of phantom limbs,
the majority of the phantom
limb patients experience
this hyper-empathy syndrome
because of the deafferentation.
- Okay thank you.
- Thank you.
- I have a question about the soul.
- Okay.
- Largely because of you, I got invited
to the Gifford Lectures after you came.
And these are the Gifford
Lectures on natural theology.
And I couldn't resist
putting in stuff on the soul
so I said, look if the
soul has to not, to exist
after you die, and goes
to heaven, et cetera,
or the other place, then
it has to, the question is,
it has to not have anything
that is required by a body.
So the question is, what
is required by a body?
And if it's required by a
body, the soul can't have it.
So you can study the properties
of the soul that way.
So can the soul see?
No.
Hence, can't see, doesn't have
a visual cortex, et cetera.
Can the soul hear?
Sorry, doesn't have the
hearing apparatus for that.
Can the soul feel touch?
No.
Doesn't have the appropriate
part of the cortex, et cetera.
And you go through this list.
Can the soul remember?
Doesn't have what is
required for memory for that.
And so you go through that,
and the next question is,
does the soul have a
personality or your personality?
So the question is does personality depend
upon the brain in any way?
And this is a question I asked Nina,
who knows much better than
I do, and she pointed out
that the Phineas Gage phenomenon would say
that it's lost control, it
doesn't have inhibition,
et cetera, sort of like Donald
Trump or you know, (laughs).
That's certainly one kind
of personality change,
but also there could be
larger brain injuries
that could produce sort of
positive changes of all sort
and if that's the case
then the soul would not
have a fixed personality
and therefore not your personality,
so in what case is it your soul?
So the question about personality
is something I really
wanted to ask you about,
if you've thought about that at all?
- Short answer is no, I haven't.
We should chat at length and
develop the idea further.
- Okay good.
- What's it like for a man like you
to be living in what I
call deep south California?
It's a strange culture down there
that we have no understanding of up here.
No I mean you've lived down
there for how many years?
- 25, 30 years.
25 years, yeah.
It's very surreal.
- Ah.
You have a favorite example?
(audience laughing)
- I still have to think about it.
(audience applauding)
(cheerful music)